ايوه بضخ علينا الدبابه جنب انتم متخبيين
اه في السياره احنا جنبين الدبابه انتم
جوا
السياره اخبار الحرب على غزه بايجاز اهلا
بكم رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري
يؤكد احراز تقدم في المفاوضات للتوصل الى
صفقه بين اسرائيل وحماس ويشدد على انها
الفرصه الوحيده المتاحه لتهدئه الوضع
بلينكن يقول ان قطر تقوم بدور مهم في
الوساطه وهنيه يؤكد تسلم مقترح اجتماع
باريس ويقول ان حماس بصدد
دراسته
114 شهيدا في 13 مجزره بالقطاع خلال 24
ساعه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني يعلن فقدان
الاتصال مع احد طواقمه بعد محاولته انقاذ
طفله استشهدت عائلتها في سياره كانت تقلهم
في مدينه غزه ووزاره الصحه تحذر من وضع
كارثي في مجمع ناصر الطبي وسط حصاره
للاسبوع الثاني ومنظمات اغاث تؤكد ان قرار
تعليق تمويل الاونروا يهدد حياه
الفلسطينيين في غزه وفي
المنطقه الجزيره تحصل على صور من اشتباكات
المقاومه مع قوات الاحتلال قرب مجمع
الشفاء الطبي في غزه وقصف اسرائيلي يتركز
على شمال القطاع وجنوبه كتائب القسام
استهدفت تل ابيب وضواحيها بدفعه صاروخيه
والسلطات الاسرائيليه اكدت وقوع اضرار
ماديه سرايا القدس تقول انها تخوض
اشتباكات ضاريه مع قوات الاحتلال غرب
مدينه غزه وجنوبها وجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يعلن اصابه ط 26 عسكريا في
معارك القطاع خلال الساعات ال4
الماضيه قوه اسرائيليه بلباس مدني تتسلل
الى مستشفى ابن سينا في مدينه جنين وتغتال
ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين احدهم جريح جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقول ان قواته قامت
بتصفيه عناصر من حماس اختبؤوا داخل
المستشفى وفصائل المقاومه تتوعد تقول ان
جرائم العدو لن تمر دون رد ونادي الاسير
يوثق اعتقال اكثر من الف فلسطيني في جنين
ومخيمها منذ السابع من اكتوبر الى
اللقاء